the three-point shot has changed the NBA
here's a deeper look at the trend with
actual cut up construction paper the NBA
has undergone a significant evolution
during the past decade gone are the days
of hulking centers pounding the ball
into the paint the league is now
dominated by versatile lineups with
multifaceted offensive teams attempted
an average of twenty four three-pointers
per game this season up from 14 attempts
in 2011 to 2012 the shop has transformed
from a gimmick to a game-changer and
nowhere has this trend been more evident
than in the Bay Area Steph Curry
connected on 402 threes he made more
threes in 2016 than any NBA team during
the first 15 years of the three-point
shot it all started with an effort to
reduce physicality along the perimeter a
rule change in 2004 tightened how
referees whistled for defensive hand
checking making it impossible to guard
an offensive player one on one team's
streamlined their offenses to include a
dribble penetration and kick outs which
resulted in wide open threes as teams
sought to find more high-value shots
they realized a shot worth 50% more is a
high-value area of the court the idea of
Maury ball emphasized taking shots
around the basket and from beyond the
arc
and not from mid range no team
illustrates this change more than the
Charlotte Hornets in 2015 the Hornets
finished among the bottom third of
three-point attempts and finished 11th
in the conference this season
Charlotte attempted 35% more threes
fourth most overall and made the
playoffs obviously not all threes are
effective a player's shooting percentage
dipped the further he was from the
basket Kirk Goldsberry an analyst
recently hired by the San Antonio Spurs
suggested a bold proposal let each NBA
team configure the dimensions of the
three-point line in its home
rina which is how Major League Baseball
teams have long operated with regards to
outfield walls teams could control the
variable of three-point line distance
and could build their lineups and change
their style of play accordingly when
steph curry made 12 three-pointers in a
regular season win against the oklahoma
city thunder he had seemed anomalous
even for him but that pinpoint accuracy
represented more than just a
record-setting performance we are well
into the new age of the NBA the league
has forever shifted and it should only
get more fun from here on